with the tightest possible biosecurity
scientists around the world are urgently
trying to make a vaccine against the
corona virus 70 possible candidates are
in development next week a British
prototype vaccine will start tests in
500 volunteers the Oxford team is so
confident that it'll work there they'll
start manufacturing doses even before
the trials have finished so while the
trials are going on we realize that we
really have to start manufacturing
manufacturing at risk because of course
if the vaccine fails nobody will want B
vaccine doses but we're hoping to have
about a million doses maybe by September
ready for deployment that's a big ask
but it's not impossible and that's our
ambition today three vaccines are
already in clinical trials two in the
United States one in China in Britain
that government has launched a vaccine
task force to speed up the development
and manufacture here at the number-10
news briefing the chief scientific
adviser told me the government's keeping
its options open just to put some again
realism on vaccine development each
single project does not have a high
probability of success so although
everyone goes out with great enthusiasm
and we hope they work it's never the
case that you know you've got a vaccine
that's going to work but the vaccine
could come from anywhere
GSK and so know if you've announced
they're doing a vaccine together which
is fantastic news most the big companies
are doing vaccines this is going to come
from somewhere
we just need to back lots of horses at
the moment and to make sure we're in a
great position to access a vaccine when
it occurs vaccines are usually tested in
three stages of clinical trials in phase
one the jab is given to a small number
of healthy volunteers to confirm that
aren't serious side effects in Phase two
several dozen volunteers are given
different doses and perhaps boosters to
ensure it triggers a good immune
response and finally in phase three is
given to several hundred people to see
if it protects them against the virus
given the urgency the last two stages
could be run in parallel to speed up
development
but one senior scientist warned even
that won't save us from grim month ahead
the recent estimates even from the chief
scientific officer is that after this
wave which could kill you know we could
see 40,000 deaths by the time it's over
we could only have maybe 10 15 percent
of the population infected or covered
and so the idea of herd immunity would
mean another five six more waves maybe
government scientists are working on the
principle that widespread deployment of
a vaccine is still 12 to 18 months away
and until then social distancing of some
form will be needed to suppress the
virus Thomas More Sky News